it's been many years but I'm pleased to
welcome back to the program C Edmund
Wright who's a columnist for Breitbart
American Thinker also author of WTF how
karl rove and the establishment lost
again and that what we talked about last
time you were on I mean it sort of
relates to what we're talking about
today which is Steve ban and Donald
Trump Breitbart first just very
generally what's your sense of right
Bart's relationship with Trump in the
sort of post Steve Bannon era
well it's interesting I was reading some
comments today on the Breitbart forum
and there was an article a very very
critical article of Donald Trump it was
posted yesterday on Breitbart called him
amnesty Don in fact right and I was
reading the comments and there's a lot
of anti Trump comments on there there's
a lot of pro Trump comments still as
well a lot of people say hey I trust
Trump regardless you know and a lot of
people calling him out for what appears
to be a little bit of a cave on the
amnesty issue or maybe a big cave on the
amnesty this year you had a blog post
where you talked about how your
relationship with Steve Bannon became
sort of strained when your level of
support for Trump if I understood it
correctly was not up to the standards or
demands that Steve Bannon had for what
your support should be did I get that
writing can you sort of elaborate on
that you kind of got it right but not
exactly so you know clarify my support
of Trump was not up to what the bribe
our readers wanted and I couldn't fake
it and I wouldn't fake it my support
wasn't up to what bannon's was what Matt
oil's was that said they still you know
liked me as an anti-establishment writer
you know being able to narrow in on the
Republican Party establishment and their
problems but you know having in some
sort of standoffish feelings about Trump
was just not something anyone at
Breitbart as far as the readership
really wanted so I just kind of backed
away a little bit and what was keeping
you from being as exuberant about Trump
as maybe others wanted you to be
um he's really not a conservative I
would have preferred more someone like
Ted Cruz who's you know more solid
conservative or maybe even Scott Walker
who had shown some success fighting the
liberal of statute was constitutional
over John Kasich for example um and you
know quite frankly Trump is governed a
lot more conservatively than he
campaigned he's governed a lot more
conservatively than he's taught you know
for the last 30 or 40 years that's not
that thing so let me go back just a
couple sentences so you preferred Trump
over Jeb Bush for example on policy what
policy of Trump's did you like better
than jeb Bush's as a conservative again
well firstly it wasn't really on policy
per se oh yeah it you know Jeb is a
moderate he's a typical Republican
establishment moderate yep and keep in
mind a lot of Trump supporters think
Trump indeed Jeb Bush that's not really
true Jeb was never going anywhere the
only people who thought Jeb Bush for
president in 2016 was a good idea you
know we're like 20 commentators in
Washington DC no one outside that you
know there's more of an aversion for
family political dynasties and the
Bush's pushed it with having two of them
there was no way the Republican primary
electorate was going to put a third Bush
up there but Jeb Bush is just he's not
confrontational enough in fact in 2011 I
wrote an article where I said Trump's
willingness to confront would actually
be a very valuable lesson for the
Republican Party that never talking so
if I'm understanding you correctly it
wasn't that Trump's policy appealed to
you because like you said you're a
conservative and Trump's not really a
conservative it wasn't his policy that
appealed to you more than Jeb Bush it
was that he would confront other people
right he would fight and again it just
goes back and I wrote something back in
2011 I called translating trumpet it was
interview with the Rush Limbaugh's show
where Trump went hard after Obama went
hard after the Democrats and I thought
okay this is what we need to do Mitt
Romney would not do that Jeb Bush
certainly wouldn't do that so what I
would have my perfect candidate would
have been Donald Trump's attitude may be
toned down 20% and maybe Ted Cruz's
philosophy Wow now that's that's
something to that's the stuff of dreams
or nightmares I guess depending on which
which side of the aisle you're on I mean
you're right what do you see as the
future of Breitbart now that there has
been sort of a split but at the same
time a lot of the Breitbart readership
it seems like the Breitbart readership
is in a sense confused or maybe split
significantly because of what's taken
place with ban and Breitbart and Trump
what do you think the future of
Breitbart will be as a publication in
what's left of Trump's presidency well
that's a tough one I guess if I I could
answer that I could get Alexander Marlo
and say look I'm worth a bunch of money
to you you know I think a lot of it's
going to depend on how Trump's
presidency unfolds it'll be very
interesting for example to see how this
this latest thing with dr. and the
dreamers and maybe path to citizenship
and maybe not unfolds you know there was
kind of a sumption during the primary by
by a lot of hardcore pro Trump early
adopting voters that he was the most
hardcore the most consistently hardcore
on issues like deportation what-have-you
and that was really never the case he
was all over the board on that issue for
he was pretty firm on the border so I
think it'll be interesting to see how
the reality of Trump unfolds versus
maybe the projection of Trump and I
think a lot of the hardcore voters you
know really bought into yeah you
mentioned daca
I mean I'm curious how do you think
Trump handled the recent I don't even
know what to call it
situation around daca and negotiations
on the government shutdown well you know
Trump I think there's competing forces
inside Trump and I don't mean that to be
negative necessarily I think on the one
hand you have the Stephen Miller
hardline tied to his hardest core base
and then on the other hand you have a
guy who you know he doesn't really when
you get right down to it unless you've
personally offended him he doesn't want
to upset you so and he likes to make a
deal so I think there's going to be some
tension within not only the Trump
administration but maybe in Trump's
heart mine as well where he goes with
this did you get the sense like I did
that Trump was almost like confused as
to why there even was a shutdown in the
sense that you know he had put out a
couple different ways that he thought it
could be averted he said hey get me a
clean dhaka bill and I'd be willing to
do that but then that sort of evaporated
at another point he said if I get
anything bipartisan on paper I'll sign
it but then he didn't do that like I was
getting the sense that he almost was
kind of confused as to why there even
was a shutdown you know I don't know
about confusing there's a lot of
confusion about shutdowns in Washington
and across 350 million people yeah I
come from the conservative wing of the
party that shutdowns not a bad thing
necessarily I also think that when you
go back and look at the what's called
the Ted Cruz shutdown in 2013 all the
Republicans were complaining that was
going to kill him in the 2014 midterms
yeah actually it came back to be a net
positive in that how do you so well he's
shut the politics of a shutdown are very
confusing I would only say that Trump
never claimed to be an expert on the
Civic's of how our government ran that
was part of his appeal to a lot of
people so I would just maybe chalk it up
to some of that he just wants to get
things done and I think he the movement
of Washington frustrates him what do you
think is to blame for this most recent
shutdown well again I might say credit
instead of blame you know I I think
Chuck Schumer's sort of played the part
this time that Ted Cruz played in 2013
without the filibuster you know but what
I think is interesting is you and I may
never agree on who's to blame per se but
the Republicans are not losing this in a
PR standpoint nearly to the extent they
generally have in the past
well they I mean I'm a little
I'm not you and I might not agree but
I'm not sure you're agreeing with with
what you've said in the past cuz when we
interviewed you back in October of 2013
you talked about the shutdown and you
said as far as that shutdown you you
said quote obviously I think with the
Democrats controlling the White House in
the Senate it obviously can't be a
Republican shutdown so by that same
standard that that you sort of gave me
in October of 2013
this can't be Schumer's fault right I
yes and no the problem is if you get
into the nuts and bolts of who caused
the shutdown you have to go through
arcane Senate rules right that's one
thing who get who is at fault is is
ultimately who gets the blame for it
rightly or wrongly I have just kind of
you know accepted that the truth of
who's really at the bottom of a shutdown
is never going to be important what's
only things important is what the
perception is on that actually we agree
surprisingly I've said before that I
believe that these shutdowns
particularly because most elements of
the government actually do keep running
I believe that it's a political football
that you can either benefit from or be
hurt by I question how much people
actually vote based on their perception
of who is to blame for a shot down but I
actually believe that it's effectively
almost 100% a perception issue and it
sounds like you agree yeah I do agree
with that and I think there's other
variables too you know I think most
Republican voters agreed with Ted Cruz
on his stance on Obamacare and that's
why eventually it helped the Republicans
i i'm not sure the democrats want to go
that far for daca the way Shermer did I
mean I guess we'll see in the 2018
primaries and then into the 2018 general
midterms when it comes to those midterms
what do you see as the voting issues
that will determine not only how people
vote but the level of enthusiasm and
what turnout will be because in these
midterms traditionally the party that
holds the White House loses seats in the
house and or Senate it didn't happen in
2002 for george w bush and i think we
have being in a very recently post 9-11
moment to sort of look at as to why that
was sort of an out
but what do you think will sort of
dictate how the 2018 midterms go boy a
lot there I'd like to comment real
quickly first 2002 midterms were
probably directly result of the Paul
Wellstone Memorial when Tom Harkin
hijacked that thing and it became an
embarrassment just enough to move the
needle is my theory I think right now
it's way too early to judge the 2018
midterms really think this government
shutdown thing kind of being Bendel is
the Schumer shutdown seem to move the
needle on the generic congressional
ballot but I think nine months from now
the biggest thing the Republicans have
going for them is nine months of
increased take-home pay is result of tax
reform that's where they're gonna have
to hang their hat to counter the the
dynamic you mentioned which is true
normally the first midterm after new
president is a reaction to that well
what what about an issue like I had a
caller recently who is a big Trump
supporter who said for me the wall is
the issue and he initially said if
there's no progress on that wall by 2020
I might not vote for re-election for
Donald Trump is that an issue which at
this point seems almost laughable that
we're gonna have a Mexican paid for wall
in progress by the nine months from now
do you think that will be a voting issue
for Republicans not so much in 2018
because Trump's not on the ballot and
nobody is tied to the issue of the wall
the way Trump is yeah you know just like
that but yes I mean I think Trump could
definitely lose some support over the
wall if there's not some sort of
progress made on it or at least the
perception of progress
now speaking very candidly with me
Edmund as you said you are a
conservative Trump is not a conservative
and that was the source of some of your
hesitations in terms of your support for
Trump when you hear Trump during the
campaign say something like I'm going to
build a wall in Mexico is going to pay
for it aside from whether you like that
idea or dislike that idea do you believe
that Trump truly thinks that's something
he's going to do or do you recognize it
as
relatively far-fetched I think it's
far-fetched but I do think that he is
very I think he's very insistent on
securing the border whatever combination
of wall fence virtual fence drone or
maybe patrol boats on Falcon Lake for
example you know it's a long complex
border geographically I think he's very
I think he's very serious about securing
the border I think the wall just kind of
became up you know a shorthand version
for that I do think a lot of people
bought into it more literally than maybe
Trump ever met and I think he played to
that at the rallies but I think Trump
understands that the wall is gonna be a
combination of different things just
from a logistical practical standpoint
now from a national security standpoint
of course the reality is that most
people who are here in the US under what
we would call illegal circumstances did
not physically cross the us-mexico
border right so do you think Trump knows
that and more importantly do you think
he cares because it's much less
appealing to talk about we will target
visa over stairs that doesn't have the
same cachet as talking about building a
wall yeah okay game you get down to what
the reality of our politics David is
that yes we perception often Trump's
reality right again I think Trump has a
vision for a secure border and a
sovereign state I don't think he's that
interested in the details of how he gets
there and they dressed up for a positive
comment that's just that's just kind of
the way he's always managed he's always
been the big picture guy yeah and he's
all had people do the details and with
the exception of trade where I think
maybe he gets a little too involved I
think that's the way he's gonna run the
border security situation and
immigration as well who could have
predicted that the election of Donald
Trump would have me seen eye to eye with
you Edmond you know just five years
after we had basically no agreements
whatsoever and in our first interview
it's really quite a unique experience
the world of Trump isn't it yeah you
know the Trump movement and I separate
Trump from the Trump move and I actually
have a lot more
with some of the Trump hardcore
supporters that I ever did or ever do
with Donald Trump himself
attaboy huh the Trump movement divided
the Republican Party not just in base
vers establishment you know which is a
little nuance at Rush Limbaugh I hadn't
figured out yet it also divided the base
into two party really cut through the
Republican conservative libertarian non
Democrat base if you will whatever the
universe is it really cut it into four
pieces and we have a lot of confusing
cross currents as a result well at least
he's pro-life right as of being 69 years
old he became pro-life and that actually
I think did carry a lot of weight with
some important groups that helped elect
him I would agree with that I think they
were perhaps remarkably uncurious about
some other things but yes I would agree
with your assessment of that and he came
down counted where I wanted him to come
down so I'm I understand what you're
saying I'm just not gonna complain about
that per se all right see Edmond right
columnist for Breitbart and for American
Thinker great to catch up with you after
all these years all right David let's do
it again